so who's hungry venoms
oh I've been talking about this one in
what and all the ways that could
possibly go wrong for so long I think
honestly would have been remiss of me
not to actually watch and now review
things so it's fine in a way I almost
kind of wish it was worse i I mean brain
didn't part of that's my headspace today
I'll be blunt about a day of recording
I've had a really lousy day and I I was
kind of hoping for something that was
gonna be utter trash just like I'd not
not so that I could rip into it but just
let has like a cleanser I don't know if
this experience makes any sense but like
last year around the same time actually
when I was still doing 90s comics
retrial as a podcast I had a lousy day
but then I read brigade
number one for that podcast and it's an
awful comic but it was exactly the right
level of stupid for me in that moment
and I'd love to the reading experience
as much as it was a bad comic and I kind
of hoped for something along those lines
with venom and honestly it's a little
bit too good for that that said it's not
great here's what they got right the
character of venom himself I do want to
emphasize the character the effects are
they're not bad they're not especially
well integrated the effects never look
like they are physically they're in the
same world as real people is is
basically what it comes down to so you
know when you have the somebody to sort
of come off him a little bit he's
talking to the face yeah you can tell
he's looking through it it doesn't look
like he's looking at anything and and
you know and that effect where they're
like part of the head opens and you see
partners taste that still looks that
looks
terrible now look terrible in the
trailer so you know that the effects are
iffy but when I say if they got the
character right I do mean the character
they got I am surprised how well Eddie
Brock works and actually how well they
were able to capture his failings in the
absence of spider-man because usually
Eddie's failings as a character are
funneled through his blaming of
spider-man for all his problems in his
hatred of him so when you remove that I
think the opioid the question most of us
had was how do you how do you retain
that element of his character when the
mechanism by which we've always had it
in the comics is gone and they actually
did it pretty decently I'll end up
getting into spoilers a little bit later
but sort of initially basically like
he's a guy who he's he's kind of a
righteous jerk I mean honestly you know
he wants to do good he's a investigative
reporter he you know he's looking into
you know the issues of homelessness and
he's trying to take care of people that
he knows the name of the doorman at the
newspaper he works at or in the news
organization or whatever it is and like
he knows the name of the woman at the
convenience store he goes do you know
his name of the homeless one you know so
like he knows people that he cares about
people but at the same time he is a bit
of a self-serving jerk so like and this
is not really spoiler it happens very
early he steals information from his
fiancee who is a lawyer for this company
that he has suspicions about and he sees
that she gets an email about a case
because her firm represents this company
and he steals that information and it
gets and what ends up happening after
that is he gets fired she gets fired and
but he then proceeds to blame the guy
who runs his coming a guy named Drake
that's a resumes character and he blames
Drake for everything but and very
rightfully points out to him you did
this this is your fault
these are the consequences of your
actions and it does manage to
captur you know the fact that the guys
the guys kind of a jerk like he loses
sight of the impact of what he does he
doesn't always think it through and he
does and but when that happens when he
screws up he doesn't he doesn't accept
blame for that he blames an external
source and by retaining that that
actually stays really true to Eddie as a
character and then the dynamic between
between him and venom the symbiote yes
they despite the early trailer saying
symbiote it's very obvious that they
went back and rerecord all the dialogue
to say symbiote
after the internet basically shamed all
of Sony by the fact that they did brows
that aren't thing right and the trailers
but I like his interaction with the
symbiote as well and I will say that
that relationship and that dynamic is
not nearly as front and center as it
should be or at least the development of
it it feels like it jumps forward at
several points across the movie like we
jump to it
talking to him pretty quickly we then
you know jump to the two of them arguing
before you know we've even really got a
gotten a sense of much of anything and
then then it's like feeling like oh
they've got a real connection we're
giving all these things and their points
that like it work but like we're missing
the connective tissue of how this
relationship between them is developing
you just kind of jumps from point to
point to point which is unfortunate
because it is one of the highlights of
the movie I do think overall the eddy
himself and and him in the symbiote are
the best parts of the movie I just wish
they were in a better movie and that's
what it comes down to this is this is
real bog-standard this is if you asked
like your average comic book reader to
outline of venom movie without
spider-man I would lay down money nine
out of ten of them are gonna outline
basically this movie it's
it's very by the numbers it's very
predictable it is exactly what you would
think it would be plot wise there's
really nothing unexpected that happens
in the entirety of the thing you know it
just kind of hugs its way along what
you'd expect
you know establishing Eddie Eddie's now
down on his luck Eddie gets a tip Eddie
gets the symbiote Eddie is on the run
from people want to get the Simba get
back there's another guy with a symbiote
he's got to fight that guy with the
symbiote it's it is exact it's that's
what it is and again I'm not gonna
spoiler any of that because actually all
of that was information you had in the
trailer so unfortunately it's just a bit
dull as far as the rating goes the fact
that this pg-13 instead of are it's
really easy to see where the cuts were
made I don't I do not believe that it
would have been a substantively
different film if it was our I think
it's just a matter of all the kills with
you know tendrils and people getting
stabbed with bits of symbiote and and
you know people getting their heads
bitten off and whatever else are just
fairly bloodless I feel confident in
saying that the r-rated version of this
probably would have been exactly what
you see maybe with a few more f-bombs
and there would have been blood splatter
added to a lot of the lot of the action
scenes but otherwise probably would have
been the exact same movie so like so
Eddie is good also his is his
performance chemistry with Michelle
Williams who plays an his his fiancee
very quickly ex-fiance
that works they've got they've got good
chemistry together so but then the plot
is basic like it's not it's not bad but
it's just so it's so boilerplate it is
so generic it's like they forgot to come
up you know with the twist on the
formula it feels very plug-and-play it
feels like it's the exact same structure
that you could use for almost if any
- hero story it really does but then we
get to the thing that just flat-out
does not work that's the villain that's
Drake he's awful he's really terrible
and it's a shame because there's one
scene there's one moment where I see the
version of Drake that would have worked
and this is a little bit later on and
there's a scene where he is talking to
someone trying to get them to give him
information and he sort of goes no look
just listen to me and he talks very
sincerely very calmly and in a way that
is believable that someone would trust
him in that moment unfortunately it
doesn't work because even prior to that
we've seen him giving his Villa ma this
guy monologues so much like the world on
the brink of collapse human beings are
the parasite my oh my god it's like the
book of of megalomaniacal villain
cliches and he just memorized all the
quotes it's so bad and also most of the
really dumb things circle around him and
or his organization I'm gonna start
getting into specifics of later plot
stuff so maybe consider that spoilers if
you really like venom as a character
maybe give it a whirl because as a
character he does pretty well but
overall the movie it's it's the epitome
of a weight for streaming and rent it
thing for me as far as I'm concerned but
so there were parts that I laughed out
loud when I was not supposed to be
laughing on there were actually a fair
number of flat-out good jokes mostly
having to do with the interaction
between Eddie and venom but there were
this parts there's a chase scene you've
seen it in the trailers you know it's
the classic San Francisco chasing yo go
boom over the big hills and whatnot
so that see that seat is going on and
they're chasing Eddie with drones which
okay it's San Francisco it's Silicon
Valley and the
life foundation or corporation or
whatever the heck it is seems to have
its fingers on a lot of pies you know
it's it's into space exploration and
pharmaceuticals and you know advanced
tech and you know presumably all this
sort of stuff so I think that they have
drones isn't what a question it's that
these drones or just being flown at like
impact they're just being flown down to
impact them and they blow up on impact
so they're being flown into the street
into cars and like all this stuff is
just blowing up first of all this that's
the stupidest use I can possibly think
of for a drone and and I mean like
you're leaving behind so much evidence
like it hits the ground and it explodes
and now it was under shrapnel and
there's components and there's all this
stuff that the police are gonna be
picking through because you just blew up
a section of the street with you friggin
drone and it's it's just so ridiculous
that this happens in the middle of San
Francisco and we're in what is
ostensibly supposed to be the real world
that this is happening it's like it is
some of the stupidest things I've seen
trying to be passed off for a world that
is more or less meant to be reality and
this is compounded by the fact that you
know the guy's got a rocket first of all
he's got a rocket like within spitting
distance of a major metropolitan area
that's thing one and then thing to he
you know the bad guy arranges for a
launch and he is like no we're not gonna
do the prep do it now is like yeah
because you don't need clearance like
from the friggin Air Force or who or who
knows whatever else before you launch a
rocket on US soil what oh my god I mean
like the fact that he he could just did
order it like on a whim it's like ya
know like that maybe that's a really
nitpicky it didn't be bother me that
much but like yes Tom it's really dumb
and it's again it's unfortunate I just
wish the movie was better and the
villain isn't great even when he
gets his own Simba then becomes riot you
know he's just kind of there and he
doesn't look as good as venom as I said
then the venom effect is a little iffy
in the first place riot doesn't look
better and you know the fight is it just
is what it is and like I don't know how
this happened but after all the
criticism that amazing spider-man to God
for putting the literal last shot of the
movie idea at least before the credits
started rolling of that film in the
trailer you know the start of the Rhino
fight they did the same thing here
because that whole um you know he's
threatening the guy he's like yo
cavorting like a turd in the wind that's
the last scene of the movie
thank puddin is it true I cannot I do
not understand how Sony could have
possibly done that again like that how
do you not learn how a money like the
one thing I'll give this credit
certainly if I'm gonna compare it to the
amazing spider-man 2 is that for as much
as it is a kind of clunking kind of
predictable it is still its own story it
is its own movie it is not just an
attempt to set up all the other
spider-man related stuff that has been
announced it actually doesn't blatantly
set up anything other than its own
sequel which does mean do not bother
hanging around for a Tom Holland cameo
there is none what there is as far as
this stuff there is a mid credit
sequence with which sets up carnage now
I cannot remember if the actor who they
have playing Cletus Kasady who will
become carnage was announced anywhere
he is currently listed on the IMDB page
in that part I can't I cannot remember
if he was announced ahead of time or not
if he was I forgot who it was and seeing
that was like okay I'm not gonna lie I
kinda do want to see him play carnage I
think that would actually be really cool
doesn't like on that basis alone I I
really kind of hope we get to sequel but
it's not because it's good um and then
there is a truth that's the mid-credits
Equus there's a there is a post-credits
but it's detached from everything it's
just a segment out of spider-man into
the spider verse and I am pretty sure it
is just the section directly lifted from
that film so that's what you get if you
stick to the end so don't bother waiting
around for Tom Holland he isn't there I
think I'm right but yeah you know what's
the best way to explain this movie this
is the first movie that I can remember
in decades that has a song and the O and
the credits that and the Sun the name of
the song is also the name of the movie
with that repeated like repeatedly in
the song you know like men in black Wild
West that style it's that and Eminem
does it yeah that's that's the kind of
movie we're dealing with
it's not a waste your time it's not a
waste your money if you are a fan of
venom you might even get something out
of it but this is not a rush to the
theatre sort of situation votes but
venom have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's a whole
bunch of stuff you can do there's links
and there's buttons including a link to
the patreon check them out if you feel
like it if you don't don't worry about
it because remember you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]